djay sloth asks how did you get started
on your YouTube channel
well there's a lot of paying desperation
and a desire to be myself so it inspired
me to do something creative and I just
needed that outlet so I kept at it and
kept going thanks for the question
purge asked how does it feel to be the
second best team in rayman legends i
gotta say you bested us in skill I can't
deny that I'll meet you at the bar after
the game Mercer Lee and Hart asked
where's the blacksmith while I found him
and I took his tools
MLP e/m atom mad asks do you have any
tips for making good videos for your
channel you always want to approach
something that you do to make it
something that you're proud of make
videos that you want to see make things
that you would be proud of Platina 32
asked what's my favorite polaris channel
besides my own well I really like the
game gross when I first ran into
egoraptor I kind of fangasm doll over
yeah rah jonesy 235 asked what's my most
embarrassing moment well back when I was
a kid my brother told me that 911 3 ice
cream so I dialed it hung up immediately
and the police were sent to my house I
was grounded for about a year after that
béla 3 asked what's my favorite video
game of all time way back when I was a
kid again we didn't have many games so I
played earthbound over and over again
it's one of the most charming and
interesting games I've ever played and
no experience has mashed it yet so I'd
have to say yeah that's my favorite
nickel asks what's my favorite game from
whose line is it anyway
I liked pretty much all the games but I
have to say my favorite is impossible
mission because it's the only one where
Colin could make Ryan crack up go long
Dabo asks if you could be a superhero
what superpower would you be I've
thought long and hard about this and
I've always come to the conclusion that
controlling time is always going to win
EBU 100 asks bacon or bacon I prefer my
bacon on the skin of the pig that I got
it from
man leader Basques if I have bad enough
dude to beat cinnamon toast Kenan and
arm wrestling match well I don't want to
say he's a little baby man
swanky Jake asks what do I do in my
downtime beside YouTube I have to say I
spend most of my time in the wilderness
punching down trees that's it
riley o'malley asks how would you rule
woman with your super manliness you're
not turned on here the mega hammer asks
what was my favorite toy as a kid I have
to say I'm a video game nerd from deep
down in my youth my favorite toy was my
Super Nintendo because me and my brother
could play together new was better than
any toy I ever made although that
workshop where you made gummy candy was
pretty nice too ah
B C gags asks if I'm so manly
how was pole dancing pole dancing
requires more muscle strength and
coordination than you could possibly
imagine and I own that bowl
I am captain man asks what are my tips
for being manly well I have to say it's
a day-by-day thing
you just got to struggle with it start
off by bench pressing elephants punch
trees every day and move the women
Newell asks how do you come up with a
stuff in your videos is it all stuff
you've known before
well let's plays are basically like
improvisational comedy and with that you
need to know what you're talking about
start reading get as many references in
your pocket as possible if you know
stuff the more you know the funnier you
can be derping Woolf asks do I have any
tattoos well only this one a teen asks
how do you shave in the morning well I
just get in a fight with a mountain lion
and let it claw it off my face jokela
Murray asks am I still taking girly
plier applications well I'm not gonna
say I'm not but don't you want this
Crammer Steen asks where's drunk
minecraft unfortunately Bob moved to
North Carolina and he's funnier than
I'll ever be acting dolphin asks what's
the secret to my incredible manly good
looks well lots of smoking and lots of
bacon
Jesus angel asks what do you to become
man fight bear fight man a lot of you
been asking to hang out with me want to
know what it's like to hang out with
markiplier this bear did
oh hey I was going thanks so much for
stopping by Marco pliers manly AMA we
had a lot of fun answering a lot of
questions hope you had fun I know I did
so hope you learned some stuff too I
mean not just the men out there the
women out there too there's a lot to
learn from just answering these
questions and learning what it is to be
a man and while also discovering more
about me so thanks so much and be sure
to stick around Polaris go because
there's gonna be a lot more cool stuff
in the future and once again thanks so
much for subscribing
I always appreciate your support